the busiest man in sports show business
right now kind enough to call in from
New Orleans Mike Tirico how are you
doing Mike I'm not busy compared to you
Alan
stop it now come on no I mean you go
you're going from Yankee Stadium
probably touching back to say hi to the
family and then heading off to New
Orleans to call Thanksgiving night game
essentially wait a week the family got
to come to New York for the game was a
good time but okay wife's to Syracuse
alum also so we got to see see the the
Irish and do a number on Syracuse and
then up to the studio to the show on
Sunday night with Toni and Rodney and
home for a day and now here we are New
Orleans Thanksgiving with it it is a
it's fun to be part of football on
Thanksgiving everybody likes to be home
pretty family out Thanksgiving there are
a lot of people who do have to work and
call on football games I did a bunch of
them during college football to the last
three years the NFL if you're not home
watching football there's nothing like
being a part of that experience for
folks at home so really looking forward
to tomorrow night and it's it's do or
die so Falcons Mike there's no doubt
about that
four and six go to four and seven and
that division and certainly in a
conference where there's a ton there's a
ton of gridlock at five and five that's
a problem
you're right rich and if you play it out
for Atlanta you know the back end of the
week the Sunday night er that we have
that Allen Chris will have with green
Blake Green Bay play Minnesota if you
think Green Bay wins that game and the
Lions beat the Bears and you get a bunch
of people all those things are getting a
stock piling of teams that are five five
or five five in one or five and six
that's an Atlanta wins that's the best
hope they have to be a part of that
wildcard run down the stretch I'll tell
you the game it really hurt them will be
the Cleveland game the game they lost
two weeks ago to Cleveland they were
building momentum remember we saw them
the opening night they lost to
Philadelphia to start the season they're
the losing streak in there they're there
one important then they went three in a
row and you feel like here they come you
know if they can get a couple here
they're gonna be right in the wild-card
mix lose to Cleveland and then the
Dallas game on Sunday was a good close
game at the end of the game the Cowboys
made the drive downfield to get the
field goal Dallas that was playing well
as you see it every week you watch the
games
with your guys just like I do with Tony
and Rodney getting set for football
night you start to watch Dallas a week
oh gosh it was a ten days ago now that's
Sunday going into the Philly game rich
you think okay
Dallas is done here there's no way off
the Monday night loss to Tennessee
they're gonna go to Philly Eagles are on
a bye week they're not gonna beat the
Eagles of this stretch away they beat
them then they win last week against
Atlanta Washington has the injuries up
upfront men to Alex with and that Dallas
is probably the team that looks like the
favorite in the NFC it's such a
strangely this time of year things can
switch so fast they can I know certainly
since the Saints just beat the brakes as
our friend Stewart would say all off of
the Eagles and I mean you you've called
many a games special game in the
Superdome the reopening the night of
obviously the gleason blocked punt and
all the Monday Night Football games that
you were able to call in that building
it seems to me breezes playing the best
he's ever played and this could be the
best Saints team he's ever quarterback
to which Sean Payton my it's ridiculous
to think about that Rick and then but
you think about this other than Michael
Thomas can a good football fan a guy
watches NFL Network during the week a
guy watches the Sunday games a gal who
watches the Sunday Night Football game
ken can you name other saints for some
wide receivers trade Quan Smith is I
know but other than that you're right
quality Club Smith is not a guy came out
of Alabama's oh no not good you see
after the run they're having right now
and all that he was part of that team
last year comes in as a third round
rookie but you know probably more people
could identify Calvin Ridley of the
Falcons as a rookie impact wide receiver
within tray Quan Smith but the point is
to what you asked in the question Brees
and Peyton together have been absolute
magic and not just for one year or two
years as we get to this era now where
after Monday night people feel like the
game has changed and this is the new NFL
these guys have been rolling at this
kind of pace what
they've had the right group around them
and healthy since 2006 since that those
who come together and that reopening you
mentioned of the Superdome and that
special season they had and they are
still doing it and I'm excited when I
get off the phone with you to go over to
their practice and go visit with them
there's those guys always get me excited
about football and the trends in the
game and the new concepts there there is
good a head coach quarterback marriage
on the offensive side of the ball as
we've ever seen that's giving a nod to
Bella checking the defensive stuff over
the years Mike Tirico here in the Rich
Eisen show him before you you head off
to that practice I do want to hit you in
a couple other items including Notre
Dame you were at the mic for a week one
still only Michigan's only lost Notre
Dame has still not lost a game this year
how good do you think this Notre team
Notre Dame team is compared to other
teams that you may have been watching on
TV like the rest of us here Mike Richard
I think they're really good I do I don't
know if it's because they are not in
look but most of the conversation in
college football this is said about
friends and it was absolute 100% respect
and care for a lot of good people a lot
of the conversation around college
football emanates from ESPN's shows I
don't think I don't think a lot of the
guys see Notre Dame enough to appreciate
them because they're not on the network
on a regular basis we have seven of
their games during the year I go back to
the Georgia game last year that they
lost 20 to 19 in South Bend and I
remember saying as we walked out of the
booth though Flutie and I are walking
eyes had done their names a lot better
than I thought they were because they
can hang on the field with the Georgia
team that I think can go a long way this
year and they got to the to the playoff
and we'll play that at the game so this
is a pretty good Notre Dame team talent
wise and as the year has gone on people
are seeing more and more and more of
that their front floor has been good
they've got two very good linebackers
Julian love their corner is going to be
one of the finalists for the Thorpe
Award he's an outstanding cornerback
they've had good safety play and when he
and book came in at quarterback he's it
kind of Drew Brees like guy he's about
six
he gets the ball out on time
ridiculously on target he leads the
nation in completion percentage and he
has done a terrific job of allowing
their receivers their skill players to
grow do I think they can beat Alabama I
don't know do I think they can beat
Clemson I don't know I know those two
teams are a notch above but I think
Notre Dame will be very competitive on
the same field with those teams I don't
think they're outclassed in any way and
Michigan's defense has been good since
the jump and they were good in the
second half of that game - I know and
Notre Dame beat them with the guys not
their starting quarterback anymore and
without their best running back so that
should say everything you need to hear
about the quality of Notre Dame and I'll
say the last point on them Syracuse is
offense since Dino Babers has been there
other than one game against Clemson they
move the ball against everybody they
move the ball they've gained yards they
were shut down I know the quarterback
was hurt they were shut down and I've
never seen Syracuse as offense under
Babers not be able to move the ball even
on really good teams so every bit of
evidence so far is Notre Dame is closer
to two than they are for right now in my
book well I know he established Mike at
the top of our conversation then you've
been on the road for a bit but you know
we've have everyone who is listen to us
converse before knows that you make your
home in the state of Michigan I don't
what's the sense
big week here what do you think this
sense is here big mega huge we got a
richness I hate to say it's a pivot
point for the Harbaugh and urine and
Michigan mm-hmm because I think Jim's
gonna be there for others just the gut I
don't know anything but I just feel like
it's an important important game for
them they have everything going now this
defense is terrific
Ohio State is given up yards like
nobody's business the strength of Ohio
State they're gonna win games by
outscoring people can they outscore
Michigan so it puts the onus on
Michigan's defense to come up big and if
Ohio State's score this is what I'm
gonna be interested to see what's it the
Buckeye score she touchdowns early and
it looks like it's gonna be a game in
the 30s not a game in the 50
your 20s right hmm it's horrible gonna
let Michigan be aggressive on offense or
is it gonna be let's protect this game
with power run that kind of stuff I'm
fascinated to see that if Marilyn can
hang 50 on Ohio State Michigan should be
able to put up big numbers so the test
to me Saturday and your Wolverines rich
is being open dynamic and explosive with
the ball and play calling on offense
that is what a scientist e noon Saturday
I'm not gonna lie to you Mike I'm
vulnerable right now I'm a very
vulnerable man of course
are you kidding cuz you point out I mean
you're right nobody knows what what Jim
Harbaugh's shelf life is going to be I
think it's gonna be a long time we had
his brother John on the show yesterday
and we're talking about how you know his
dad and his mom are probably gonna have
Thanksgiving and they live next door to
Jim right they listen up so I mean you
can't beat that in this day and age as
you talk about your bringing your family
on the road I mean it's sports life is a
great one but you know family life is
sometimes takes a backseat certainly in
the coaching world but when you talk
about pivot points you're right I mean
this is it this is the should happen
moment this is the this is the time for
it to finally happen moment and if that
doesn't happen I don't even know I I
can't even finish the sentence there's a
thing
it'll be tough here's the thing on the
longevity of Harbaugh just from my view
of being around living in Ann Arbor for
the last 19 years knowing Jim for about
that law and covering him all the way
back to his playing days and getting to
know him I think there are two guys who
are among those if not the only two
people on Jim Harbaugh's personal Mount
Rushmore that's his dad and Bo
Schembechler and I think he's got the
chance to be both all-in-one in the
Michigan job he has a chance to be the
all-time legendary coach at Michigan who
made Michigan football Michigan football
again right and his dad was a longtime
beloved coach and you talk to anybody
who played for Jack Harbaugh or coach
with him and they swear by him and
they do a podcast together Jack
Harbaugh's around that team all the time
I went to see them earlier in this year
I spent more time talking to Jack it's
Jim I got more information out of Jack's
than I did at a gym to be honest with
you
I think those the two guys that he just
holds as role models for his life and I
think he wants to be like them and I
think he's got the chance to do it all
in one job at his school a place that he
loves and his kids are going to the same
elementary school he did nan Arbor and
he's at the same church that he went to
his parents are there and all that so I
think he wants to be there long term I
don't think this games a complete
referendum on that but I do think it's
important to continue the process this
is the year to beat Ohio State because
they've got everything going Ohio State
has it's turmoil they have the struggles
defensively don't give if you're my
advice to Michigan like they needed my
advice to my Michigan fans friends don't
let your team be conservative
offensively it's a game where Shea
Patterson needs to be aggressive they
need to be aggressive offensively
everything you've held back all year go
go do it take the game don't little
Hollow State deliver the punches in this
one and I wish I wish you luck Saturday
I have a great cast
Thursday night Mike with me the whole
family all country will be settled in so
enjoy it thanks thank you and Susan the
kids enjoy I look forward to it thanks
seeing you Mike that's Mike Tirico the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience